hello robin
hey steve so today we're talking with
robin mcpherson who's located in san
francisco and who is a polyglot and who
has a channel robin mcpherson i'll leave
a link here in the description box and
he puts out interesting videos such as
you know same as i do about different
aspects of
language learning based on his own
experience
robin you were saying just now that one
of your most
popular videos has been on the subject
of
uh how to think and effectively so i'll
let you describe let you describe the
video and maybe we can discuss that a
bit
yeah because the reason i want to talk
is with this with you about this is that
in that video i try to present
like a newer perspective because i find
that this question is asked all the time
how do i start thinking in a foreign
language and i have found that lots of
people
give a response that isn't
super helpful which is often like well
the goal is to not think right the goal
is to just speak which may be true but i
don't think it's it doesn't satisfy the
this like big gap in this learner's
desire for like but i want to know what
should i be doing so in that video i
presented this idea that one of the best
things you can do
is to actually sort of
practice talking to yourself and in the
video i went into some different
techniques because people sometimes feel
uncomfortable talking to yourself but
the reason why i suggested this is that
when you think about thinking in general
it's a bit like an inside voice right
and so i have found that once i get to a
point where i can i'm not super
concerned with speaking amazingly well
uh it's just that i i start to talk to
myself a lot and i have found that this
is a really good way of becoming
comfortable with this sort of internal
dialogue that maps quite well to this
idea of thinking in a foreign language
so that's my thought the so the first
thing is i'm curious what you think
about that but the biggest thing i would
love to hear from you about is that the
most common question in the comments i
have is people are terrified that by
talking to themselves or just talking at
all they're going to be repeating their
mistakes and sort of you know
causing permanent or semi-permanent
damage because they're going to be just
internalizing their mistakes so what do
you think um about this idea of sort of
talking to yourself or maybe even
journaling it doesn't have to be spoken
this this idea of an internal dialogue
uh and then how do you feel about this
concern that so many people seem to have
that they'll be repeating their own
mistakes by speaking at all
well you know i think
everyone has their own uh
path you know or the things that they
like to do so i mean i have tried
talking to myself i really can't keep it
up for very long
uh
i might say a few phrases during the day
phrases that are running through my mind
as i'm learning a language but i have
not been able to do much talking to
myself so i really can't talk about that
as a
you know what what how beneficial that
is or might not be
um
you know as you know my emphasis on
input so i just find that uh
as you know through a lot of input
eventually the the new language just is
meaning i'm no longer translating it's
just meaning
and similarly as we start outputting in
the language we begin by doing a lot of
translating uh from our own language and
in time we start reacting
with the words and phrases that we've
basically socked into our brain through
a lot of input so
right i just let that process uh happen
and i am not aware of speak though
so when you do speak though
again it's not even let's say it's not
even just to yourself when you start
because i you know i remember watching
way back when you did your korean 90 day
challenges and you would go out to the
laundromat uh the korean owners
do you worry about that you're okay
you're gonna be making mistakes and
repeating them and that those are gonna
become internalized okay i uh i can't
say that i don't worry about making
mistakes i prefer not to make mistakes
but if i if i let my worrying about
mistakes inhibit me then i won't speak
so i just go i let it come out however
it comes out and uh hopefully and in
fact typically it gets better very very
slowly it doesn't get better very
quickly
uh
insofar as ingraining mistakes i don't
believe that happens
uh as long as you maintain your input
activities so right there you have
people you know and this is the case
often with immigrants they have sort of
achieved a certain level where they can
output certain things and they
understand certain things and that's as
far as they're ever going to get in the
language
in my case
when i listen and read i continue my
input activities even when i lived in
japan i continue my input activities
listening all the time reading all the
time trying to notice how the language
works so that
actually i make fewer and fewer mistakes
because i'm becoming more and more
familiar with the language but if you if
you don't make that effort
if you just you know here's the language
that i'm going to use yeah you you might
ingrain some mistakes as you know i'm
not a great believer in speaking early
but i also don't believe that i think
it's irrelevant i don't think you would
ingrain mistakes i think it's possible
to make a mistake today not make it next
week and then make it again the
following week so uh you know
yeah so i don't see that as a problem
i'm just not a big fan of speaking early
but if i'm in a situation like when i
lived in japan where i have people
around me speaking the language i will
obviously take advantage every chance i
get and i won't worry about it
yeah i agree and and i i have a very
similar approach by and large where i
tend to not i don't well i don't speak
early
and b i just i tend to not really worry
about um
speaking uh it just sort of happens but
but i do i have found that the more
advanced i get in a language the easier
it becomes to fix my mistakes right so
a simple example is when i was living in
japan i remember living there and i was
telling a story
and for whatever reason in that story i
kept referencing um
a lady who was part of the story and i
kept saying like
this word meaning woman
and someone who corrected me and they
said it's not wrong but it'd it'd be a
lot more appropriate for this particular
you know setting if you said jose
instead of honor
and i i swear i because i was already at
a very advanced level
i almost never made that mistake ever
again and those people who were who
became close friends of mine they
pointed out multiple times not just that
one like
as they would correct me and as they
would sort of uh give me suggestions i
would internalize them very very quickly
and i've just always found that
that's why i don't worry so much about
yeah maybe i get a couple of bad habits
maybe i'm repeating the same error but i
know that as i get better and better and
better it's in my experience it's going
to be easier and easier to actually
patch those things up
and when i do i'll actually understand
why have you had any you have any
thoughts on that have you had any
experience well um
you know
first of all you can't rely on people
correcting your mistakes right
what i find happens is you start to
notice things that you hadn't noticed
before
and so first of all to say ona is not
wrong
and in certain situations you say
ononokata
or you might say jose
and you have to develop a sense of which
one is a appropriate in which context
and that sense develops over time
after having been involved in different
situations whether as a participant
listening to other people talk watching
tv whatever it might be you start to
develop a better sense you start to
notice things over time now having
someone point something out to you is
one way of noticing it
it's not a bad idea to read the grammar
book once you're very good in the
language in the target language
because it again helps you notice things
but
yeah
i just think we notice more and more
things as we get further and further
along in in the language and i i don't
worry about and i don't think people
should worry about mistakes they make in
the early stages because they just don't
have enough experience
in the language so how are they possibly
going to know these things and even if
they read the rule i mean
studying a rule or having a teacher
teach you something
may have very little impact you may
learn it then understand it then forget
it the following week
and notice it again six months later so
yeah i i don't worry about games in the
early stages no
i i remember a long time ago you used to
always talk about the um i mean much it
was like the five keys of language
learning and one of them was the ability
to notice three keys actually but yeah
three okay there we go yeah that was i
mean the first time you said that must
have been ten years ago yeah i think
um and i have found the same thing to be
true and i've honestly found even i
think one of the the greatest abilities
that polyglots develop or just people
who learn lots of languages um
over a period of time is it's just
becoming sort of hypersensitive
um to noticing
things like and it becomes sort of
second nature so when i'm
listening to someone speak um
even in a new language i've now i know
what i should be at least looking out
for and i just notice lots and lots and
lots of things and i find that you just
end up with tons and tons of data points
and so if i'm learning swedish for
example and i'm talking to someone or
watching a television show or listening
to a podcast if i hear a word that i
recognize
i'm noticing many many things about that
i'm noticing what was the context that
it was used in or like what were the
what was the phrase like you know i'm
just noticing lots of things and i think
that is a skill that polyglots develop
is just that ability to to know what to
look out for and then notice a lot more
stuff more quickly yeah i i think the
process might be a little bit less
deliberate than that i think it just
happens naturally
uh because we have been exposed to so
many languages we are naturally without
even wanting to to be that way we're
more curious about language how
languages work and and
we're more confident as learners i mean
these are things that happen that's why
uh people who speak uh a few languages
five four five six find it easier to
learn new languages they're just more
observant it's like if you if you play
three or four sports it's going to be
easier for you to pick up a fifth sport
so just to close out here so tell us
which languages you speak
um so i speak french japanese italian
spanish portuguese german
swedish
um and i'm now learning uh mandarin
chinese oh my goodness okay yeah all
right
not quite as many as you i know you have
a you have a surprising panel yeah i
didn't know that many when i was your
age either okay any final thoughts for
my viewers
uh i just want to say it's a pleasure to
be on the channel again
i was when i was in japan that was when
i first started learning uh more
languages than just japanese and i
actually had
a massive playlist of
all the videos on this very channel and
i remember i would while doing the
dishes ironing i would listen to them
and i i honestly learned a lot of the
principles that guided me through
the next 10 years so it's just a
pleasure to be on your channel and uh
yeah thank you okay tonight learning is
all about enjoying it
it is okay yeah thank you bye robin hi
steve
[Music]
you